[Music]
The Carter Center in Atlanta Georgia was
founded by former President Jimmy Carter
and his wife Roslyn nestled in a Park
area the center's work stretches around
the world striving to ensure human
rights and ease suffering it's a
democracy democracy program focuses on
helping fledgling democracies conduct
free and fair elections mostly by
sending observers to monitor voting
they're doing that again this year but
the election they're monitoring may
surprise you Barry Peterson reports from
Atlanta
Guyana South America 2020 election
observers from The Carter Center found
problems but a recount five months later
led to a peaceful transition of power
Tunisia North Africa 2019 another of the
more than 110 elections worldwide where
Carter Center observers watched over
contest
[Music]
our southeast Asia 2015 their first free
elections their first step towards
democracy where they found many could
not vote because of violence or
discrimination these are all the
elections we've observed since 1989.
David Carroll is director of the
Democracy program at the Carter Center
in Atlanta and he personally observed
elections this year the Carter Center
has a new troubled election it is
focusing on hours what does that mean
that means we've realized that the the
situation in the in the United States
the threats to democracy and to our
institutions here are greater than in
many countries around the world both
sides are selling mistrust in election
results as did Democrat Stacey Abrams
when she denied losing the 2018 Georgia
governor's race we won
and Donald Trump when he lost in 2020.
there
is
[Applause]
this year even before the first votes
some candidates already say they won't
accept election results unless they win
that's the nightmare scenario if people
don't agree to a peaceful transfer of
power I mean that that is the
fundamental element of of a democracy I
understand what you're saying but I
sense really and truly there's a bit of
fear in what you're thinking about
oh a great amount of concern and fear of
what could happen in this country if we
are not able to get ourselves back on on
the right track fear of what
fear of you know this country no longer
being a place that is genuinely
Democratic hardcore take no prisoner
partisans get the publicity but
surprisingly it's not what most
Americans want a new poll showed
two-thirds of respondents want
candidates who will compromise to create
change the Carter Center will observe
elections in three states this year
Georgia Arizona and Michigan watching
voting or election preparations
experience it got in 2020 when it
observed the recount in Georgia that
confirmed a Biden Victory and in 2020
Gabriel Sterling now Georgia's interim
deputy secretary of state issued a blunt
warning as emotions on both sides boiled
over and some election officials faced
death threats it has to stop
someone's gonna get hurt someone's going
to get shot someone's going to get
killed
what do you feel overall just bring the
focus back out of Georgia and across
America
are you worried about the direction this
is going
generally speaking I remain hopeful in
these situations and what we have to
remember is not all these people are
evil people all these people who are
thinking the election was owned they
believe in their heart of hearts their
actions are protecting American
democracy and like 2020 this year there
are more threats to officials and
volunteer workers it is taking a toll
when you're a poll worker or thinking
about being a poll worker and you face
these kinds of
threats let's be honest how does that
affect your mental health it really can
have quite a serious impact on people's
mental health especially in the the
longer term Avery Davis Roberts is
associate director of The Carter
democracy program and a veteran of
several overseas elections how does that
play out they tell you stories about
being afraid to be at home by themselves
because of the threats they've received
some people just start crying men women
Republicans Democrats these are threats
that have really impacted election
officials from all walks of life the
midterm election is a dry run for the
big prize the presidential election of
2024. will there be a free and fair 2024
or will we have lost our way by then
asked me after 2022. the message is as
clear as it is ominous the many battles
over democracy and voting may end up
destroying democracy itself
for CBS Saturday morning Barry Peterson
Atlanta
interesting when he says will we have a
free and fair 2024 and he says ask me
after 2022. also early in the piece
talking about this idea that the threats
here are greater than in other places in
the world in trying to have a democratic
election
I was still watching it because you know
I felt the wash of history in the moment
of watching that piece go by because
we've seen this before in our country
um many times but we've gotten over the
hump the question is will we this time
around